Seção 3 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite librivox.org.
Dom Casmurro, de Machado de Assis.
Capítulo 11. A promessa. Tão depressa vi desaparecer o agregado no corredor, deixei o esconderijo, e corri a varanda do fundo. Não quis saber de lágrimas, nem da causa que as fazia verter a minha mãe. A causa eram provavelmente os seus projetos eclesiásticos, e a ocasião destes é a que vou dizer, por ser já então história velha. Datava de dezesseis anos.
Os projetos vinham do tempo em que fui concebido, tendo-lhe nascido morto o primeiro filho, minha mãe pegou-se com Deus, para que o segundo vingasse, prometendo se fosse varão, metê-lo na Igreja. Talvez esperasse uma menina. Não disse nada a meu pai, nem antes, nem depois de me dar à luz. Contava fazê-lo quando eu entrasse para a escola, mas enviuvou antes disso. Viúva sentiu o terror de separar-se de mim, mas era tão devota, tão temente a Deus, que buscou testemunhas da obrigação, confiando a promessa a parentes e familiares. Unicamente para que nos separássemos o mais tarde possível, fez-me aprender em casa primeiras letras, latim e doutrina, por aquele Padre Cabral, velho amigo do Tio Cosme, que ia lá jogar as noites.
Prazos largos são fáceis de subscrever. A imaginação os faz infinitos. Minha mãe esperou que os anos viessem vindo. Entretanto, ia-me afeiçoando à ideia da Igreja, brincos de criança, livros devotos, imagens de santos, conversações de casa, tudo convergia para o altar. Quando íamos à missa, dizia-me sempre, que era para aprender a ser padre, e que reparasse no padre, não tirasse os olhos do padre. Em casa brincava de missa, um tanto às escondidas, porque minha mãe dizia que missa não era cousa de brincadeira. Arranjávamos um altar, Capitu e eu. Ela servia de sacristão, e alterávamos o ritual, no sentido de dividirmos a hóstia entre nós. A hóstia era sempre um doce. No tempo em que brincávamos assim, era muito comum ouvir a minha vizinha: "Hoje há missa?" Eu já sabia o que isto queria dizer, respondia afirmativamente, e ia pedir hóstia por outro nome. Voltava com ela, arranjávamos o altar, engrolávamos o latim, e precipitávamos as cerimônias. Dominus, non sum dignus... Isto que eu devia dizer três vezes, penso que só dizia uma. Tal era a gulodice do padre e do sacristão. Não bebíamos vinho nem água, não tínhamos o primeiro, e a segunda viria tirar-nos o gosto do sacrifício.
Ultimamente, não me falavam já do seminário, a tal ponto que eu supunha ser negócio findo. Quinze anos, não havendo vocação, pediam antes o seminário do mundo, que o de São José. Minha mãe ficava muita vez a olhar para mim, como alma perdida, ou pegava-me na mão, a pretexto de nada, para apertá-la muito.
Capítulo 12. Na varanda. Parei na varanda, ia tonto, atordoado, as pernas bambas, o coração parecendo querer sair-me pela boca fora. Não me atrevia a descer a chácara, e passar ao quintal vizinho. Comecei a andar de um lado para outro, estacando para amparar-me, e andava outra vez e estacava. Vozes confusas repetiam o discurso de José Dias: — "Sempre juntos..." — "Em segredinhos..." — "Se eles pegam de namoro..."
Tijolos que pisei e repisei naquela tarde, colunas amareladas que me passastes à direita ou à esquerda, segundo eu ia ou vinha, em vós me ficou a melhor parte da crise, a sensação de um gosto novo, que me envolvia em mim mesmo, e logo me dispersava, e me trazia arrepios, e me derramava não sei que bálsamo interior. Às vezes dava por mim sorrindo, um árduo riso de satisfação, que desmentia a abominação do meu pecado. E as vozes repetiam-se, confusas: — "Em segredinhos..." — "Sempre juntos..." — "Se eles pegam de namoro..."
Um coqueiro, vendo-me inquieto e adivinhando a causa, murmurou de cima de si que não era feio que os meninos de quinze anos andassem nos cantos com as meninas de catorze; ao contrário, os adolescentes daquela idade não tinham outro ofício, nem os cantos outra utilidade. Era um coqueiro velho, e eu crio nos coqueiros velhos, mais ainda que nos velhos livros. Pássaros, borboletas, uma cigarra que ensaiava o estio, toda a gente viva do ar era da mesma opinião.
Com que então eu amava Capitu, e Capitu a mim? Realmente, andava cosido às saias dela, mas não me ocorria nada entre nós que fosse devera secreto. Antes dela ir para o colégio, eram tudo travessuras de criança. Depois que saiu do colégio, é certo que não restabelecemos logo a antiga intimidade, mas esta voltou pouco a pouco, e no último ano era completa. Entretanto, a matéria das nossas conversações era a de sempre. Capitu chamava-me às vezes bonito, mocetão, uma flor; outras pegava-me nas mãos para contar-me os dedos. E comecei a recordar esses e outros gestos e palavras, o prazer que sentia quando ela me passava a mão pelos cabelos, dizendo que os achava lindíssimos. Eu, sem fazer o mesmo aos dela, dizia que os dela eram muito mais lindos que os meus. Então Capitu abanava a cabeça com uma grande expressão de desengano e melancolia, tanto mais de espantar quanto que tinha os cabelos realmente admiráveis, mas eu retorquia chamando-lhe maluca. Quando me perguntava se sonhara com ela na véspera, e eu dizia que não, ouvia-lhe contar que sonhara comigo, e eram aventuras extraordinárias, que subíamos ao Corcovado pelo ar, que dançávamos na lua, ou então que os anjos vinham perguntar-nos pelos nomes, a fim de os dar a outros anjos que acabavam de nascer.
Em todos esses sonhos andávamos unidinhos. Os que eu tinha com ela não eram assim, apenas reproduziam a nossa familiaridade, e muita vez não passavam da simples repetição do dia, alguma frase, algum gesto. Também eu os contava. Capitu um dia notou a diferença, dizendo que os dela eram mais bonitos que os meus. Eu, depois de certa hesitação, disse-lhe que eram como a pessoa que sonhava. Fez-se cor de pitanga. Pois francamente, só agora entendia a emoção que me davam essas e outras confidências. A emoção era doce e nova, mas a causa dela fugia-me, sem que eu a buscasse, nem suspeitasse. Os silêncios dos últimos dias, que me não descobriam nada, agora os sentia como sinais de alguma cousa, e assim as meias palavras, as perguntas curiosas, as respostas vagas, os cuidados, o gosto de recordar a infância. Também adverti que era fenômeno recente acordar com um pensamento em Capitu, e escutá-la de memória, e estremecer quando lhe ouvia os passos. Se se falava nela em minha casa, prestava mais atenção que dantes, e, segundo era louvor ou crítica, assim me trazia gosto ou desgosto mais intensos, que outrora, quando éramos somente companheiros de travessuras. Cheguei a pensar nela durante as missas daquele mês, com intervalos é verdade, mas com exclusivismo também.
Tudo isto me era agora apresentado pela boca de José Dias, que me denunciara a mim mesmo, e a quem eu perdoava tudo, o mal que dissera, o mal que fizera, e o que pudesse vir de um e de outro. Naquele instante a eterna verdade não valeria mais que ele, nem a eterna bondade, nem as demais virtudes eternas. Eu amava Capitu! Capitu amava-me! E as minhas pernas andavam, andavam, andavam, desandavam, estacavam, trêmulas e crentes de abarcar o mundo. Esse primeiro palpitar da seiva, essa revelação da consciência a si própria, nunca mais me esqueceu, nem achei que lhe fosse comparável qualquer outra sensação da mesma espécie. Naturalmente, por ser minha, naturalmente também por ser a primeira.
Capítulo 13. Capitu. De repente ouvi bradar uma voz de dentro da casa ao pé. — Capitu! — Mamãe! — Deixa estar que já vou! — Vem cá, Capitu! — Já vou, mamãe!
Não me pude ter, as pernas desceram-me os três degraus que davam para a chácara, e caminharam para o quintal vizinho. Era costume delas, as tardes, e as manhãs também, e as pernas também são pessoas, apenas inferiores aos braços, e valem de si mesmas, quando a cabeça não as rege por meio de ideias. As minhas chegaram ao pé do muro. Havia ali uma porta de comunicação mandada rasgar por minha mãe, quando Capitu e eu éramos pequenos. A porta não tinha chave nem taramela, abria-se empurrando de um lado ou puxando de outro, e fechava-se ao peso de uma pedra pendente de uma corda. Era quase que exclusivamente nossa. Em pequenos fazíamos visita batendo de um lado e sendo recebidos do outro com muitas mesuras. Quando as bonecas de Capitu adoeciam, o médico era eu. Entrava no quintal dela com um pau debaixo do braço para imitar o bengalão do Doutor João da Costa, tomava o pulso à doente, e pedia-lhe que mostrasse a língua. É surda, coitada, exclamava Capitu. Então eu coçava o queixo, como o doutor, e acabava mandando aplicar-lhe umas sanguessugas ou dar-lhe um vomitório, que era a terapêutica habitual do médico.
— Capitu! — Mamãe! — Deixa de estar esburacando o muro, vem cá.
A voz da mãe era agora mais perto, como se viesse já da porta dos fundos, que dava para o quintal. Quis passar, mas as pernas, há pouco tão andarilhas, pareciam agora presas ao chão. Afinal fiz um esforço, empurrei a porta e entrei. Capitu estava ao pé do muro fronteiro, voltada para ele, riscando com um prego. O rumor da porta fê-la olhar para trás, ao dar comigo, encostou-se ao muro, como se quisesse esconder alguma cousa. Caminhei para ela, naturalmente levava o gesto mudado, porque ela veio a mim e perguntou-me inquieta: — Que é que você tem? — Não é nada, balbuciei finalmente. E emendei logo: é uma notícia. — Notícia de quê? Pensei em dizer-lhe que ia entrar para o seminário, e espreitar a impressão que lhe faria. Se se consternasse é que realmente gostava de mim. Senão, é que não gostava. Mas todo esse cálculo foi escuro e rápido, senti que não podia falar claramente. Tinha agora a vista não sei como.
— Então, você sabe? Nisto olhei para o muro. O lugar em que ela estivera riscando, escrevendo ou esburacando, como dissera a mãe, vi uns riscos abertos e lembrou-me o gesto que ela fizera para cobri-los. Então quis vê-los de perto, e dei um passo. Capitu agarrou-me, mas ou por temer que eu acabasse fugindo, ou por negar de outra maneira, correu adiante e apagou o escrito. Foi o mesmo que acender em mim o desejo de ler o que era.
Capítulo 14. A inscrição. Tudo o que contei no fim do outro capítulo foi obra de um instante. O que se lhe seguiu foi ainda mais rápido. Dei um pulo, e antes que ela raspasse o muro, li os nossos dois nomes, abertos ao prego, e assim dispostos:
Bento Capitolina
Voltei-me para ela. Capitu tinha os olhos no chão. Ergueu-os logo, devagar, e ficamos a olhar um para o outro. Confissão de crianças, tu valias bem duas ou três páginas, mas quero ser poupado. Em verdade, não falamos nada, o muro falou por nós. Não nos movemos, as mãos é que se estenderam pouco a pouco, todas quatro, pegando-se, apertando-se, fundindo-se. Não marquei a hora exata daquele gesto. Devia tê-la marcado, sinto a falta de uma nota escrita naquela mesma noite, e que eu poria aqui com os erros de ortografia que trouxesse, mas não traria nenhum, tal era a diferença entre o estudante e o adolescente. Conhecia as regras do escrever, sem suspeitar as do amar. Tinha orgias de latim e era virgem de mulheres.
Não soltamos as mãos, nem elas se deixaram cair de cansadas ou de esquecidas. Os olhos fitavam-se e desfitavam-se, e depois de vagarem ao perto, tornavam a meter-se uns pelos outros. Pai futuro, estava assim diante dela como de um altar, sendo uma das faces a Epístola e a outra o Evangelho. A boca podia ser o cálice, os lábios a patena. Faltava dizer a missa nova, por um latim que ninguém aprende, e é a língua católica dos homens. Não me tenhas por sacrílego, leitora minha devota, a limpeza da intenção lava o que puder haver menos curial no estilo. Estávamos ali com o céu em nós. As mãos, unindo os nervos, faziam das duas criaturas uma só, mas uma só criatura seráfica. Os olhos continuaram a dizer cousas infinitas, as palavras de boca é que nem tentavam sair, tornavam ao coração, caladas como vinham.
Capítulo 15. Outra voz repentina.
Outra voz repentina, mas desta vez uma voz de homem. — Vocês estão jogando o siso?
Era o pai de Capitu, que estava à porta dos fundos, ao pé da mulher. Soltamos as mãos depressa, e ficamos atrapalhados. Capitu foi ao muro e com o prego, disfarçadamente, apagou os nossos nomes escritos. Pádua saiu ao quintal a ver o que era. — Vocês estavam jogando o siso? perguntou. — Estávamos, sim, senhor, mas Bentinho riu logo, não aguenta. — Quando eu cheguei à porta, não ria. — Já tinha rido das outras vezes, não pode... Papai quer ver?
E séria fitou em mim os olhos convidando-me ao jogo. O susto é naturalmente sério. Eu estava ainda sob a ação do que nos trouxe a entrada de Pádua, e não fui capaz de rir, por mais que devesse fazê-lo, para legitimar a resposta de Capitu. Esta, cansada de esperar, desviou o rosto, dizendo que eu não ria daquela vez por estar ao pé do pai e da mãe dela.
De mais, amava particularmente os passarinhos. Tinha-os de vária espécie, cor e tamanho. A área que havia no centro da casa era cercada de gaiolas e de canários, que faziam cantando um barulho de todos os diabos. Trocava pássaros com outros amadores, comprava-os, apanhava alguns no próprio quintal, armando alçapões. Também se adoeciam, tratava deles como se fossem gente. Negócio de relatório. — Você já viu o meu gaturamo? Está ali no fundo. E a buscar a gaiola, ande ver...
Que o meu desejo não era nenhum, creia-se facilmente, sem jurar pelo céu nem pela terra. O meu desejo era ir atrás de Capitu, e falar-lhe agora do mal que nos esperava, mas o pai era o pai, e de mais amava particularmente os pássaros. Tinha-os de vária espécie, cor e tamanho. A área que havia no centro da casa era cercada de gaiolas e de canários, que faziam cantando um barulho de todos os diabos. Trocava pássaros com outros amadores, comprava-os, apanhava alguns no próprio quintal, armando alçapões. Também se adoeciam, tratava deles como se fossem gente.
Fim da seção 3.